das ist ein nagelneuer fahrradweg bei
kirchdorf an der amper im landkreis
freising von kirchdorf richtung
burghausen durch das an partei die
jubeljahre die gehört dazu sie sind
planungsfehler verschlammt im
landratsamt selbst mountainbiker
wolfgang lacher weiß nicht so recht was
er dazu sagen soll
das ziel ist das wirklich ein radweg
wird wann das soweit ist ganz einfach
und die straße dritte leben und die
radfahrer müssen jeden profi aus fahren
macht spaß ist eher was für inline skate
oder soja hierfür ganz grobe morgen bei
geblieben parcours auf und ab geht's für
genau 500 meter
dann ja dann ist der parcours sowieso
schon wieder zu ende
[Applaus]
also auf zur erlebnistour nach kirchdorf
inn landkreis freising ist sehr viel
unterwegs oder und haben schon mal so
einen weg schon mal gesehen
genial akku oder doch einfach nur
versemmelt darüber spreche ich jetzt mit
andreas schmidt jetzt mitglied des
gemeinderates hallo herr schmitz ja
jetzt ist dieser radweg in ganz
deutschland bekannt war dass er geplant
das gehört für platin ja geplant war es
so nicht das ist absolute planungsfehler
vom landratsamt freising gewiss gewesen
und man hat es einfach kurzfristig
versucht den fehler zu korrigieren und
jetzt schaut es so aus wir aussieht
zumindest macht das ja das fahrradfahren
ein bisschen spannender bleibt der weg
jetzt auch so laut landratsamt freising
wird das so bleiben wir sind natürlich
dran hier nun vielleicht korrekturen zu
durchzuführen oder dass das landratsamt
uns hier noch mal eine korrektur erlaubt
es ist so planungsfehler wurde ja
eingestanden dass wir hätten eigentlich
entscheidungs vorschläge bekommen so
vielleicht den ersten und den letzten
lüge entfernt oder den fraktionen
wirtschaftsweg ab senkt damit die huckel
auch entfernt werden können
wir sprechen von einem planungsfehler
wie genau kam es denn zu den hügeln und
was verbirgt sich unter den hügeln wird
da irgendetwas wichtiges geschützt oder
ein gab es da einfach eine miss
kommunikation wie können wir uns das
vorstellen
ich will natürlich vermeiden dass jetzt
die leute zum glauben anfangen
also das ist natürlich so dass die feld
einfahrten die die felder die östlich
vor dem radweg sind die landwirtschaften
die fahrzeuge einfahren können und der
radweg war zuerst eben planiert und dann
hat man festgestellt dass die welt
einfahrten vergessen würden
dann haben wir kurzfristig die
feinplanung geändert und hier fast
asphaltiert und dann haben wir auch zum
ersten mal dieses ergebnis gesehen
nun hat das ganze jahr 3,3 millionen
euro gekostet wurden diese steuergelder
gut eingesetzt also grundsätzlich das
ist ja nicht das rad der fahrradweg das
kleine stück was 3,3 millionen gekostet
hat sondern das ist die ganze
straßensanierung inklusive
brückensanierung über die amper da ist
ja wieder kleine teil der fahrradweg
grundsätzlich sind wir unglaublich froh
dass wir diesen fahrradweges bekommen
haben dass die kinder zukünftig sicher
von kirchdorf in die anderen ortsteile
wie is not in burghausen oder wippen
hausen kommen und wieder zurück insofern
ist für uns das geld unglaublich
sinnvoll investiert worden und wir
freuen uns dass man in zukunft den
radweg nutzen dürfen auch wenn er mehr
oder weniger als letzte frage an sie
sind sie denn die buckelpiste schon
entlang geradelt und wie war's war das
lustig oder hat es sie genervt
natürlich haben es gleich ausprobiert
auch mit der familie zusammen
ich glaube das ist eher amüsant die
stören gerade buckel und vielleicht
hatte jeder einen drauf wenn er in
zukunft in kirchdorf ankommt